a new royal baby is coming Megan
markle's says she and her husband Prince
Harry plan to raise their baby in a
quote gender-fluid way it's a decision
that more and more parents are making
these days she explained the trend we
have Kathy you are liberal Sherpa
joining us tonight
Kathy great to see you yeah so the core
idea is I understand it is that sex
male/female designations are creations
of society they're not real nothing
inherent is sex specific and so you can
kind of choose whether your child is a
boy or a girl is that the idea the the
child will choose what the child wants
to be we are facing a genderless future
a gender-neutral future a unisex future
so more than ever
mainstream magazines like Woman's Day
are coming out with unisex names for
children so you can name your baby
Harper or Blake so they could fit into
this future of a genderless society okay
and I wouldn't call women's day a main
service of ludicrous magazine not
mainstream but but whatever leaving that
aside and leaving aside the scientific
question of whether this is fantasy
which of course it is rather than
reality because not let me ask you why
you would want a genderless Society
isn't like the whole point that the
sexes are different and that's a that's
a good thing why would you want to
eliminate those differences well no
we're always teaching our children to be
who they want to be
Will Smith says his son is fearless
Jaden Smith is not afraid to wear skirts
on runways or dresses and he says the
son is who he wants to be he's strong
fearless you're unique and that's what
we want for our kids to be no we're not
encouragingly to be unique you just said
we're encouraging them to be all the
same unisex everyone's the same as
sexist actually okay but absolutely not
okay so it's it's in in ignoring
differences we're accentuating
differences
we're being who we want to be
were showing the children that they
could be who they want to be if the boy
wants to wear a dress that's okay the
girl doesn't want to wear a dress and
play with Barbies that's okay are you
that but I'm still looking fused about
the details
Kathy Ruo I know you're gonna come back
and fully explain this brave new world
that we're entering thank you yeah thank
you